- My name is Leslie Gross-Wyrtzen
and I am an affiliate
in the McMillan Center
in the program for African
Studies and Middle East studies.
I've also been involved with
the Program for Refugees,
Forced Displacement,
Humanitarian Response,
and a fellow for the Center
for Race, Indigeneity, and
Transnational Migration.
I remembered all of those things.
So, it is a real pleasure today
to introduce Dr. Heba Gowayed.
I'm gonna say it the long way,
who is an assistant professor
of sociology at Boston University
and currently a member of the Institute
for Advanced Study at
Princeton and her research,
which is global and comparative examines
how low income people
traverse social services,
immigration laws, and their
associated bureaucracies,
while grappling with gender
and racial inequalities.
And she's published on these topics
as well as health and
education, as I discovered,
educational access for folks from Cairo
in race and ethnic studies,
Sociological Forum,
Gender and Society in the
American Behavioral Scientist.
And today she's gonna talk
about her book "Refuge,"
which was published by
Princeton University Press,
which is an ethnography
that explores the lives
of Syrian seeking refuge in
the US, in Canada, and in Germany.
And the book, one thing
that's really exciting
about having her back here is
that the book began in
New Haven, Connecticut,
right here where Heba was
living and volunteering
among recently resettled Syrian families.
So, in the book, she
examines whether and how
these countries recognize and invest
in new arrivals humanity and potential,
shaping their economic realities
and feelings of belonging.
As countries receive refugees
through their social welfare systems,
"Refuge" raises a mirror to how
these systems reproduce social inequality.
And if we have time,
we might hear a little bit
about her next project,
which is called "The Cost of Borders,"
which thinks about borders
and border enforcement
as a series of costly
and deadly transactions.
So, I'm just gonna lay
out a few ground rules
for those in the room
and also those online.
First of all, Heba can't see
you, so if you are online,
please use the chat or raise your hand
and I will do my best to
respond to your questions
and to forward those to
her at the end of the time.
Also, if for some reason you're on Zoom
and you're in the room right now,
you need to mute both Zoom
and your speaker on your computer.
And then finally you'll just be asked
whether you consent to recording.
If you don't consent to recording
or don't want your voice
to be on the recording,
then just use the chat function
and I will repeat your question for you.
So, thank you very much.
I'm looking very much
forward to hearing more
about the book and also having
a really generative
conversation with you all.
- Thank you so much Leslie,
and thank you everybody in the
room and online for coming.
I am just gonna do the
awkward thing of trying
to share a portion of my
screen, so bear with me.
There we go, we're good.
Okay, so thank you all
so much for coming today.
I'm gonna talk to you
about my book "Refuge,
How the State Shapes Human Potential."
That it was out as of April of this year.
Okay, so as you all know
today, the world is facing one
of the largest displacement
crises in modern history.
And this is due to longstanding
realities of local violence
produced by colonial legacies as well
as newer facts of
environmental degradation
and the disappearance
of land and resources.
82.4 million people,
more than 1% of the world's populations,
one in every 95 people are
currently forcibly displaced.
And among them are 25 million people
who are displaced outside
of their country of origin
and among them, 6.7 million
or an estimated 6.7 million
are Syrian refugees, and
you know, despite the fact
that this global crisis
is ongoing, is worsening,
we're really just beginning to
understand its ramifications.
And so in this presentation,
I'm sharing with you
the findings of the comparative
ethnographic project
that followed Syrians as they began
new lives in the United
States, Canada and Germany,
countries that offered them
a resettlement and asylum,
which the United Nations
identifies as durable solutions
to the problem of displacement
and in this project,
I focus on the experience
of displaced people
who are skilled or semi-skilled,
but not particularly highly credentialed,
and who arrived each of these countries
between 2015 and 2016.
And I'm gonna argue that human capital,
which we typically think
of as a crucial determinant
of immigrant outcomes,
is itself structured
through state incorporation policy.
Further, I show that the
process of its production
is both gendered and racialized.
But before I expand on this argument,
let me first give you a
background on how these men
and women arrived to these
countries in the first place.
How they became refugees,
which is also an explanation
of their selection into the
three cases that I study.
So, the Syrian refugees in
this study lived in cities
like Homs, Syria's third largest,
where this covered market once stood,
they became refugees due
to a war that began in 2011
as a result of the
government's violent response
to civil protests for social change.
The Syrian manifestation of what came
to be known regionally as the Arab Spring.
The war took with it the sight and sounds
of the neighborhoods where
their families had lived
and the homes that they had built
and the lives of their loved ones.
And at first, people displaced
fled to areas nearby,
but eventually many of them
fled the country altogether.
And most initially crossed into countries
of immediate refuge,
countries like Jordan,
Turkey and Lebanon, which continued
to host about 83% of all Syrian refugees.
And there they registered with
the United Nations higher
council for refugees.
And the thing about this is that you know,
you have a country like
Lebanon with 6 million people
and a million Syrian
refugees arrive there.
And so this of course creates
tension with local residents.
Politicians are using it to
to foment, you know, conflict.
And so, and also there
are not opportunities,
strong opportunities for education,
strong opportunities for
healthcare and so as a result,
a lot of people felt that
there wasn't a future there.
And for those people, there
were two possible solutions.
One is resettlement and
the other is asylum.
And resettlement is
where a displaced person
is selected for travel to a third country.
They're selected based on
a measure of vulnerability.
So, things like financial burdens,
the number of school-aged children,
whether or not there's
a chronic health burden
in the household or
violence and exploitation
in those countries of immediate refuge.
And when offered
resettlement to a country,
they can say yes or no,
but they cannot choose
the destination itself.
Refugees are then vetted
for travel through
an arduous process that can
take approximately two years.
The United States and Canada led the world
on resettlement, a program that takes in
hundreds of thousands of people each year.
However, given the
sheer number of refugees
who are displaced, globally,
resettlement is a super rare solution.
So, only 1% of all displaced
people will ever be resettled.
So, for those not offered resettlement,
the other solution to
displacement is asylum.
And I'm sure many of you remember watching
in the summer of 2015 as
almost a million people
with the help of smugglers made
the treacherous journey in blow up rafts
across the Mediterranean
Sea and into Europe.
As one Syrian woman Welat
put it to me rhetorically,
"Do you know what it is to go into debt
to put your children
in the arms of death?"
Asylum is where a refugee
stakes his or her claim
by going to a country
that could offer them
legal status and applying.
By some estimates, Germany took in
about half a million Syrian
asylees between 2015 and 2016.
And recent statistic
that I looked up says 1%
of all of the German
population right now is Syrian.
So, resettlement and asylum
offer those seeking refuge
an opportunity to rebuild
their lives in well equipped,
wealthy countries with full legal status.
But what do these institutional
solutions mean for people
who have experienced such
traumatic displacement
and are embarking on new
beginnings in strange countries?
Today, we're gonna look at
resettlement and asylum,
not as ends, but as
continuations to the process
of displacement and seeking refuge.
Indeed, by the time
that the Syrian refugees
in this study had arrived
to the United States,
Canada or Germany, they'd experienced
a number of significant losses.
They'd lost their country,
arriving to a new one where their,
(Heba speaking foreign language)
or norms and traditions
were entirely different,
whose language was not their mother tongue
and where they would be ethnic,
religious and racial minorities
stigmatized by association to terrorism.
They had resigned themselves
to not seeing their family
for the foreseeable future, if ever again.
But what's more they would experience
the dimming of their potential.
In countries of resettlement
and asylum, their skills and abilities,
what we typically identify
as their human capital
did not have the same
residence as they did in Syria.
The focus of this presentation
is on why that residence is lost.
So, the term human
capital, central to studies
in economics or public health or you know,
all of the social sciences
refers to individual abilities
and qualities that make
workers productive.
Sociologists have shown that human capital
is an important determinant of immigrant
socioeconomic mobility alongside
the characteristics of
a receiving context,
particularly for the first
group of immigrants who arrives.
In other words, this literature
shows that human capital
and context together
shape immigrant outcomes.
Human capital is typically
measured cross sectionally
as years of education or
occupational histories.
It's imagined as something that
immigrants bring with them,
an independent variable
that shapes other outcomes.
However, this leaves the question,
if one had five years of Syria
in public school education
or held an occupation
as an artisan in Syria,
how does this actually
matter for their productivity
in a destination economy?
This question has been of interest
to economists by
identifying what they call
the imperfect transferability
of human capital
for immigrants who are moving
across disparate context.
It's also been of interest to
others who identify migration
as a process as disruptive
of human capital.
Some have tried to
explain this discrepancy.
Human capital theorists simply say,
"Well, you must not have the
necessary skills, right?"
Signaling theorists argue
that that doesn't really make
sense because skills are not
a recognizable thing, right?
It depends on whether or not they're seen
or whether or not people are
understood to have skills.
So, it might be that you just don't have
the credentials that
are legible to employers
regardless of the skills
you actually hold.
Yet other theorists show that the reading
of skills is shaped by racism, right?
Or that the skills of minoritized groups
are necessarily always seen as inferior.
However, these explanations
continue to treat the immigrant
as a puzzle piece entering
the labor market puzzle.
But what of the state that governs
the entire process of migration?
So, in this study I introduce a theory
of state structured human capital.
I argue looking at the early period
and through a comparative
angle that human capital
can be created, transformed,
or destroyed through
the incorporation policies
of receiving countries,
which derived from national
approaches to social welfare.
I find that incorporation systems
can intervene in two ways.
First, they can recognize or
ignore immigrant histories,
seeing people unskilled who may in fact
have skills that could be activated.
This has always mattered for
highly skilled immigrants
like doctors or lawyers.
But also in this study
I will talk about Amin,
who arrives in Germany as a truck driver
and he's worked his whole
life as a truck driver.
I show that this history of
him working as a truck driver
only matters in the German
labor market as long as
he's recognized as being
a truck driver in Germany.
Second, states can invest in
newcomer refugee skills so
that they can translate their
histories in ways that are
productive in a new setting or enable them
to acquire skills that
matter in that setting.
For instance, states can provide
language learning classes
or teach refugees in new
skill that is needed in
the receiving economy but that
they did not previously have.
It can also provide financial assistance
to allow refugees to benefit from existing
skill building opportunities
in the context of reception.
So, for these reasons I argue
that human capital is not
only a determinant of immigrant
outcomes but an outcome
structured by state
incorporation policies.
I also show that the production
of human capital is gender.
As scholars of gender have
shown institutions and services
themselves feature gendered
expectations of who is a worker.
These interact with the
Syrian's own gender expectations
where men are often seen
as primary breadwinners
resulting in different, as I will show
some surprising outcomes
for women and men.
I also show that the production
of human capital is racialized.
So, countries equip new
arrivals in their pursuit
of a good and stable life
through the very same
racist social welfare
systems that have long shaped
the contours of national belonging.
But what's more, as
scholars of race have shown,
discrimination and racist violence
diminishes opportunities
for engaging in the society
in which one finds themselves
so minoritized people
may fear being in public space.
And this was particularly true for women
who wore the hijab in this study.
So, now turning briefly to a
theory on immigrant reception,
foundational literature
and sociology holds
that immigrant welcome is contingent
on determinants including things
like race, social capital or legal status.
The focus of this literature tends
to be on long term integration
or how immigrants fit
into a national whole.
Instead, I join others who
have shifted the question,
focusing not on how immigrants
fit into a given context,
but how context works in
the lives of immigrants.
I focus on the under study
crucial initial years
in which newcomer histories
collide with new systems
to coalesce into their
first designations of race,
of legal status and of human capital.
And this early period is crucial
because it shapes where
immigrants start, right?
And how they then progress in
these destination contacts.
I focus specifically on
social welfare policies which
have long again shaped the
contours of national belonging
and from which social assistance
for immigrants derives.
Finally, I compare refugees
who because they receive
social assistance denied
to other categories
of immigrants due to
their legal recognition
as refugees are a
conservative case to explore
how incorporation policies
matter for new arrivals.
But before we get to how
refugees are incorporated
through resettlement
policies, the men and women
in this study have to
first secure legal status.
Let's talk slightly about arrival.
So, in the United States and
Canada, recognized refugees
are admitted per long
time resettlement systems.
And on your screen is
the approximate number
of Syrian refugees taken in by
each country between 2015 and 2017.
Germany, as you see,
took in at least half a million refugees.
And this was due to the suspension,
the temporary suspension
of the Dublin regulation
by Anglo Merkel that would've
otherwise kept people
at the borders of the European Union.
And legally in the
United States and Canada,
refugees have permanent residency
within a year of their arrival.
But in Germany they receive a one
to three year renewable residency
depending on their level
of protection, right?
And we could talk about these later.
We're gonna keep it light for
this part of the presentation.
Okay, so what are these countries
incorporation policies for refugees?
So, each derives again from the
social welfare system of the state.
So, in the United States, as you all know,
we have a liberal market economy.
And as one feature the United States
has limited social service system
because it treats poverty
as an individual failure
as argued for instance by Michael Katz
in "The Undeserving Poor."
In her work, Sibil Fox shows
that this approach to poverty
is inextricably linked
to the disenfranchisement
of black Americans in the United States.
Refugees only regular cash
assistance comes from TANF,
which is Temporary Assistance
for Needy Families.
The national welfare system offered
to low income people in the country.
Introduced in '96, the
program has lifetime limits
and offers low amounts of cash.
This design matches the goal of both TANF
and the 1980 Refugee Acts,
which is for self-sufficiency,
that the low income refugees included
should not be relying on
government assistance.
So, it's important to
note here that there are
other programs like Match
Program or like RCA,
but there are all sort of
limited in what the assistance
that they offer to refugees.
Canada, the second case is
also a liberal market economy,
but characterized by what's been
called inclusive liberalism.
So, what this means is that
the social service system
in Canada is generous,
providing Canadians who need it
with enough assistance to
cover their basic needs.
And this generosity
shapes the government's
proactive approach to
immigrant incorporation.
But that proactive approach is
also facilitated by the fact
that Canada has way more
restrictive policies
for admission than the
United States does, right?
So, it's whoever gets
beyond the, you know,
the welcome mat surrounded by nails,
as one writer put it gets this assistance.
But everybody else is sort of kept out.
And as Irene Bloemraad shows in her work,
immigrants and refugees
are received through
what's called state
sponsored multiculturalism.
Which means that Canada
actively recruits and seeks
to integrate immigrants into
the fabric of their society
by recognizing them as
ethnic minorities providing
instrumental and symbolic
support to them in that category.
And so it's with this express goal
of integration that
refugees there are met.
Finally, Germany is a
corporatist system which means
that the national economy
is organized by coordination
between the state, the
unions and employers
to the perceived benefit of all three.
So, the system means
there's really high levels
of expenditure on social programs
and a highly centralized
and powerful state,
which Myer Marksfried, for instance,
described as producing the German nation.
And this nation was long
comprised of ethnic Germans.
As Germany has a long history
of excluding, you know,
violently non-German people
from full integration.
Syrians entering the system
benefit from the generous
financial assistance that
exists for the German state.
However, it comes with
really meaningful conditions.
So, to enter the labor market,
which is condition of permanent residency,
you need to first excel in German classes
and then you need to
earn a German credential,
as do 85% of German workers.
So, as a result I call the asylum program
in Germany one of credentialization.
Okay, so how do refugees
experience these three systems?
Before I get into the data,
let me give you an
explanation of my methods
and a little more on key selection.
So, to compile the neat
data chart that you see
on the chart before you
involved in ethnography
conducted in three countries
over the span of three years,
I'm fluent in Arabic and in 2015
I was kicked outta my field site in Egypt.
The long term consequences of another
dictatorial backlash
against the Arab Spring.
I was living in Connecticut
when the United States here, right?
In New Haven, when the United States
began to resettle refugees
to a local resettlement agency in 2015.
And I volunteered as an interpreter there
where I met the 18 families in my project
who I got to know closely
in the coming years,
observing firsthand meetings they had
with the Department of Social Services,
negotiations with off the books
employers and interactions
with the resettlement agency,
which is also local, sorry.
So, and I recognize as I spoke to these,
you know, to these new
arrivals, how important
the United States Social
Services were to the territory.
Though they were living in a liberal city
with strong social services compared
to elsewhere in the United States,
in a very strong
resettlement agency as well,
they had tremendous trepidation about
their assistance and
also about finding jobs.
They were living under the
constant threat of American poverty.
I wondered how the
experiences would differ
if they had arrived to another country.
And at that point, Justin
Trudeau, who had run on
a platform of resettling
25,000 refugees to Canada,
won the premiership and was
making good on his promise.
And flights to Canada at
the time were inexpensive.
So, I got to Toronto in February
'cause I was a graduate
student with no money,
so I got to Toronto in
February in time to see
thousands of people crammed
into hotels and motels
and government offices trying to rent cars
to go apartment searching in what was
a brutally cold Canadian winter.
And so there I include
five families, two of whom
are related to families in
New Haven and all of whom
are selected on the basis of
the same selection process
of those arriving to the United States,
making them good comparative cases.
While Canada has a private
sponsorship program,
I include people selected
by a government sponsorship
for the sake of comparability.
Though two of the families
did receive private
sponsorship support for six months as part
of a hybrid program, which again I'm happy
to talk about in the Q and A.
And initially I visited Canada for a month
and I returned every
six months for two weeks
and maintained contact with
these families longitudinal,
vis-a-vis social media, et cetera.
I also did some focus
groups and participated
in some focus groups that
were being done there just
to triangulate this data
against a bigger populations.
Finally, with the help of the NSF
and the Horowitz Foundation,
I included the case
of Germany due to the sheer number
of refugees who were admitted there.
And because it's a welfare state
that's predicated on very different
integration approaches I just described.
So, in the summer of 2017,
I included five families
who were related elsewhere my study.
But because this research
would not be longitudinal,
I returned in the summer of 2018
to conduct additional interviews,
a sample of which were a sample of the
University of Constance's
National Survey on Refugees,
which at that time was just being launched
and these were mostly
conducted in Bavaria.
So, regarding the study sample,
as you'll see in the United
States, Canada and Germany,
I compare refugees from
similar backgrounds,
the men were truck drivers,
chefs, house painters,
working skilled or
semi-skilled occupations
but without strong formal credentials.
Now of course refugees from any place
are a diverse group of people.
There are high earning refugees,
there are low earning refugees,
but this I focus on this
specific group, okay?
And the women for the
most part, as I will show,
were also not employed in Syria
with a few notable exceptions.
However, in the German interviews I also
did interview some high earning refugees
just for the sake of comparability.
So, I am happy to talk about that.
There are some doctors and some lawyers.
Okay, so now let's turn
to what these refugees
reveal about the incorporation policy
in the United States, Canada and Germany.
So, to organize findings
in each case I describe
how refugees experience their arrival
and the assistance that they
received from the state.
I then explore how each system
structured the human capital
of these newly arrived refugees and how
that experience differed
for women and for men.
And I began with the
case of the United States
and how men and women
resettled here adjusted
to the self-sufficiency
imperative of resettlement policy.
Here I highlight the case
of Rojette and Mejed,
who just seven years
prior to their arrival
were a middle class couple
living in Homs, Syria,
just around the corner from the
covered market that I showed you earlier.
In 2010, they finally achieved their dream
of building their own home,
leaving the foundations in place to build
additional floors for each
of their three children,
the oldest of whom was
a preteen at the time.
Their enjoyment of this dream,
however, was short lived.
In 2011, they fled to Jordan where Mejed
who had owned his own restaurant became
an undocumented worker at a Shwarma stand.
This couple along with
their three children
arrived in JFK in October of 2015.
An international organization
for migration van
drove them from JFK to
New Haven, Connecticut.
They were dropped off in
a dimly lit parking lot
of an off track betting
facility at the edge of town,
known as Sports Haven.
They piled into the car
of the resettlement agency
case worker and made their way
to a low income neighborhood
of the post-industrial city.
Their apartment was on the
second floor of what used
to be a single family home
and they would soon realize
it had a mouse infestation
and there the couple
would be visited by a case worker
who would tell them what
their assistance would be.
During this meeting
they learned about TANF
for the first time, the welfare system.
They would receive $803 per month,
the benefit for a family of five.
They would also receive comparable amounts
in food stamps through an
electronic benefit transfer,
EBT, that could go towards food items.
At this meeting they also
learned that their rent
was a thousand dollars a month.
Here's a budget sheet for another family
that's early in their resettlement.
So, because people don't read English,
on the left is a clipper of the expense
and each column header is the month,
which his family translated
into their Arabic names.
Yellow highlighter is the welcome money,
federal funding, which
is $975 per refugee.
And in green is what the
family is expected to pay.
As you can see for the
first three to six months,
the resettlement agency, and again,
Iris is a much more
resourced resettlement agency
than anywhere else in the United States.
Using a mix of federal funding
and welcome money as well
as donations to the agency
would support the family.
However, the family would
immediately be expected
to pay half of the TANF
benefit towards rent
while the agency would cover the rest.
But when the assistance was up, right,
when the agency was no
longer supporting them,
so between that three and six months,
TANF cash alone, right?
$803 versus a thousand dollars
for rent was insufficient to cover it.
And so there was no
discussion in this family as
to who had to find a job, as
a household's breadwinner,
this was Mejed's responsibility.
And this brings us to the
issue of state structured
human capital tied to labor market entry.
Mejed lacked an effective social network.
His friends or refugees who
were just as poor as he was.
However, through a contact at the mosque,
he was referred to an
Egyptian pizza store owner,
he helped in the kitchen.
Mejed earn minimum wage at this job.
Due to the nature of the job,
however, he had no
control over his shifts,
which is just the nature of
shift work in the United States.
Though he tried to attend English classes,
his work schedule was unpredictable.
He also did not have the time
or energy to study after his shift.
Low income work in the United States
is characterized by precarity,
with unpredictable work
schedules and a lack
of a living wage as well as de-skilling.
In Syria, the men in this sample,
as I said before, were
carpenters, electricians,
contractors, chefs and restaurant owners.
When they met each other
in the United States,
they introduced themselves
first by their family name
but then by their man or
their their occupations.
In the United States,
most did low wage jobs.
There were dishwashers,
janitors, gas station attendants
where coworkers did not speak
English by design, right?
Because they didn't speak English.
And where they did not have the energy
or time to attend English
classes after work.
As one man put it, "I want
to work but I'm new here.
We just got here, we
don't understand anything
but you wanna push me,
'tedfeshooni' to work.
So, we work whatever, 'hayallah.'
Most work in restaurants, doing whatever,
everyone is working against their will.
No one is happy.
In other countries they allow us
to study, to get assistance.
They say you're not allowed to work
so you can learn, not here."
Meanwhile, after the
kids enrolled in school,
Rojette and the other women began
to attend English classes in the morning.
By staying out of the labor market,
the women had the opportunity
to build new human capital,
the English they were
learning and enabled the women
to do a series of tasks that
their husbands could not.
They could communicate
with service providers
and resettlement agency staff.
They could advocate for
their children in school
and they were building
for the citizenship exam
that would take that
they would be eligible
to take in five years time.
In addition, most of
the women within a year
after the resettlement took on some kind
of income earning task to
support their husbands.
The woman utilizes skills that they have.
For example, Rojette crocheted
baby clothes and flower pins.
And 26 year old Reda,
whose husband had once said
to me with finality, "Our
wives don't work," did work.
She prepared sweets,
(Heba speaking foreign language)
that her husband sold to other co-ethnics.
So, in this way the women
reimagined their existing
human capital for new
labor market returns.
However, as I learned when
I began a citizenship clinic
with the group that earlier this year,
even for the women, the
gains were short lived.
Actually earlier last year,
the gains were short lived.
None of the activities,
because they were not
recognized via a pay stub,
were seen by the Department
of Social Services
as qualified work, right?
Because you have to have qualified work,
which means you have to show a pay stub.
The women could not receive
the limited federal care,
childcare subsidy, federal, sorry,
childcare subsidies that
were available to them
because they do not have the pay stubs,
because they were not seen as working
from the eyes of the state.
Anna's family settled
in, babies were born.
Sarah joked Donald Trump is trying
to keep Syrians out of the country.
But look at us, we're
making more Syrians here.
With nowhere to leave their children,
the women dropped out of English classes.
Also, it's important to note that women
were also hindered in
their pursuit of language
as a result of anti-Muslim racism.
On your screen is a hateful message sent
to the local mosque here in 2016,
was sent to mosques
all around the country.
As hate crimes against Muslims spiked,
including incidents against
people in this study,
they shied away from being
outdoors on their own.
Reda, for instance, stopped
going to English classes
altogether after her family was attacked.
And Rojette also stopped
going for a period of time
after Reda's family was attacked.
Five years after their arrival,
none of the men and few of the women had
enough English to qualify
for the citizenship exam.
A crucial barrier to
inclusion and protection
against policies like the
travel ban that reduce
their feelings of security
in the United States.
So, to sum up, the
self-sufficiency imperative
interacted with men and
women's division of labor
to result in men entering the labor market
within months of their
arrival, which reduced
their ability to rebuild
their human capital.
Meanwhile, women staying
out of the labor market
because their husbands
entered in their stead
were able to begin to learn more English
and reimagine their skills in new ways.
But five years after their arrival,
they too did not have much
by way of language capital.
My findings linked to national data,
which shows that though refugees enter
the labor market quickly
in the United States
and are employed at higher
rates than non immigrants,
they tend to have lower incomes
than the native born and other immigrants.
And this gap is increasing
for new cohorts.
Importantly, 20 years in over half
of refugees admitted to the United States
continue to have low English proficiency.
So, the experience of refugee resettlement
in the United States is an integration
into American poverty,
which by design is populated
by people of color and
marked by stagnation.
Okay, so now that I've given you the case
of the United States, let's
turn to the case of Canada.
So, a drive of 500
miles north of New Haven
takes us to Toronto, where Venya,
a relative of one of the
families in New Haven,
lived with her husband and four children.
Venya has a laugh that
can be heard ringing down
the hallway of her apartment building.
Her husband Bassim is a
good deal older than her
and like mentioned he owned
his own restaurant in Homs.
The couple has three children,
including a son who
requires a hearing aid,
and was placed in a school
the for Canada, excuse me,
something that Venya was really ecstatic
about 'cause he was gonna
get proper education.
When Bassim and Venya arrived, COSTY,
an organization that was
managing resettlement on behalf
of the Canadian government,
housed them in a hotel.
They would be allowed to
choose their own residence.
They chose to move to Mississauga, an area
with a large Arab community
where a market around
the corner sells the
latest in Islamic fashion
and transplants the customer
to an old town soul.
Two other families in my study
chose to move to Kitchener
and Hamilton with a group
of other families starting
a Syrian community out of
the arrivals in Toronto,
people that they did not previously know.
The Canadian government gave
families a startup allowance
of $5,000 to cover first
and last month's rent.
The government also provided new arrivals
with standard issue, new
furniture for their home.
For the families resettled
through private sponsors,
the sponsors would find family a home,
purchase it and furnish it for them.
So, at a similar level. Tournament
This family received a cash
assistance of $1,600 a month,
$800 per parent in addition
to the Canadian child benefit,
which is approximately
$450 per school age child
and available to everyone who
is low income and documented in Canada.
After the first year,
the families who still
need assistance would
receive Canadian welfare,
which is a variable for
low income Canadians,
which was a few hundred dollars less
than the refugee cash assistance,
but still supported the
needs of these families.
The Canadian government, as
is clear on their website,
anticipated this transition
from refugee assistance to welfare.
So, they write when income
support from the government
or private sponsors ends after 12 months,
in most cases it is a normal occurrence
for some refugees transition to provincial
or territorial social assistance support.
So, Venya and Bassim's rent
for a three bedroom apartment
in this high rise was $1,400 a month,
which they would cover and
exceed with this assistance.
So, the families did not
need to follow the timeline
of families in the United States.
They could wait to enter the labor market.
In fact, they were incentivized to do so
because they would lose
the refugee cash assistance
if they had income from other sources.
This differentially structured
their human capital, right?
Differently structured
their human capital as
it allowed them to learn
English and gain skills.
Unlike in the United States
where men had to enter
the labor market early
and women were the ones
who could learn English, in Canada,
the opportunity was
available to both partners.
And so each morning the Bassim and Venya
attended English classes a
short walk from their home.
After a year of lessons,
their English remained halting
but enabled them to have
telephone conversations,
something that is really hard
to do in a foreign language
and something that
neither the men or women
could accomplish in the
United States at that time.
And while there was
variation in the sample as
to who attended regularly,
everyone reported that
English classes as well as
opportunities for education like courses
through which they could gain skills
or earn diplomas were free
and readily available.
The one caveat I will
say is that childcare
was a little bit spotty.
So, while in a lot of places,
childcare was also
included, in some cases,
like for a family that was in Kitchener,
it was harder to access
government sponsored childcare.
However, the system was uneven
in recognizing existing skills.
While a blacksmith in the study
could find work immediately
as a blacksmith,
for instance, a woman
who was a nurse in Syria
and who had confronted the war as a nurse
could not gain equivalency, particularly
as she lost her paperwork
fleeing from the war.
She was told she'd need
at least five years
of schooling to become a nurse in Canada.
An electrician in the study was hired in
an apprenticeship based on
his existing credentials,
but he was told he would
need to pass an exam
to become fully licensed in the country.
All three however, and
others in the study benefited
from publicly available in free education.
The blacksmith to courses on
becoming a forklift operator,
trying to find different things
because he had a bad back.
The electrician was considering
earning a certificate
in engineering since he
had to do an exam anyway,
so he figured he'd get the
next stage of his education
and the nurse took classes
in community counseling
though she wasn't sure that she could
make a full career out of it.
The existence of these
classes benefited others too.
Venya said in her usual a jovial demeanor,
"Venya that cooks and cleans is over."
(Heba speaking foreign language)
She was gonna enroll in a
class to learn to do hair
and Yasin, who was Almir
the blacksmith's wife
took classes in food prep and
began to work at a restaurant.
So, it's important to
note that in Canada, too,
hate crimes were high against Muslims.
Almost as high as they
were in the United States.
However, the families
in my study in a sense
felt insulated from it, and even though
ethnography is not a good
measure of incidents,
this feeling of security says something
'cause it was not the case
in the United States or in Germany.
One explanation is that
the Syrians in Canada,
unlike the US and Germany
could choose where they lived.
They had free mobility.
So, a lot of them live by co-ethnics,
which facilitated also their
economic opportunities.
They could also choose to
live in a cosmopolitan place
like Toronto, which has other immigrants.
However, I also think that
what cannot be discounted
is Canada's active promotion of a policy
of multiculturalism by law,
which as Irene Bloemraad describes,
means that the state is
focused on investing in people
through the aforementioned
language courses
and educational opportunities,
but also through things
like radio programming
in their language and
support for co-ethnic groups.
And so this, and these
are designed specifically
by the state to generate
the sense of belonging.
So, in sum, through investment
the Canadian government
supported refugees
expression of human capital
and gaining of new human capital
through language learning.
Though their recognition is inconsistent.
We don't see as a result
as strong of a divergence
as we see in the case of
the United States by gender.
A Syrian outcomes report done
in Canada found that among
government sponsored refugees
who arrived in Canada
in 2015, 43% had found
stable employment by 2018.
So, that's a relatively low number
as compared to the United States.
However, this has a here a
clear human capital trade off
because the same study shows that 7 in 10
of these people attended
English classes regularly,
over 80% reported feeling
that they could go shopping,
go to their doctor's office and interact
in social situations entirely in English.
And studies show that
15 years after arrival,
refugee income in Canada and
labor market participation
looks pretty similar to
that of other immigrants
and Canadians and their English
tends to be more fluent.
So, in some of the Canadian system,
by creating opportunities
for the expression
of existing human capital and the creation
of new human capital
creates a stronger sense of
sort of stability and
belonging that we don't see
in the counterparts in the United States.
Okay, so finally, what
about the case of Germany?
So, arrival in the
German case of asylum is
much more dangerous than in
the case of resettlement.
So, Iman, along with our husband Amin
and their three children arrived
in Germany in the summer of 2015.
Amin, who I had mentioned
earlier in the talk,
was a long haul truck driver in Damascus
where he was in prison due to tipping off
the resistance on a
delivery of ammunition.
After he was released from
prison by the intervention
of his boss, the family fled the country.
They first fled to Turkey
and then a year later
got on a raft to Greece.
After an 18 day trek through Europe,
including three days of
detainment in Hungary,
which Iman describes as
the worst days in her life,
including the war, they
arrived in Germany,
$400 in debt to someone
they'd met on the way.
They could not afford to travel further
to their intended Sweden.
After a welcoming arrival in Germany
that brought you Iman to tears,
they spent two days in a police camp
and then a month in a
refugee camp in Lysik,
at which point they secured their
three year temporary residency.
This was a quick turnaround.
Typically the process
takes closer to a year
to get the residency card if not longer.
Iman and Amin received assistance
from the German government
through the job center
where all unemployment assistance
is distributed in Germany.
Their rent in Dusseldorf was
covered by the job center
and they received a
monthly amount that covered
their basic expenditures
and allowed for them
to send 50 euros back home
every once in a while.
Like in Canada, refugees language learning
is the first issue of concern
for the German government.
However, unlike in Ontario,
Syrian refugees are required
to attend German classes
under penalty of reducing
their assistance or
canceling their assistance.
As a result, Amin and
Iman enrolled in classes.
In order to secure work in Germany,
they would have to accomplish
at least the level B one of German.
And so this meant
succeeding in four courses,
A levels, three A levels and
the first of your B level,
which would take a minimum of a year,
but more realistically two, particularly
for people who were illiterate in Arabic
or who were in this you
know, semi credential group.
The classes also taught
basics about German culture
and laws, which people have written about.
And you know, they tend
to take a racialized view
of the immigrant who's arriving.
But we could talk about
that in the Q and A.
But then if Amin wanted to
be a truck driver in Germany
he would need to do training through
an apprenticeship system called an
(Heba speaking foreign language)
for an additional three years.
His experience as a
truck driver and the fact
that he had gotten arrested
in tortured in prison
as a result of this
occupation was irrelevant.
It wasn't seen by the German state
as qualifying Amin to work.
In order to find work in Germany,
he would have to abide by
the same rules as Germans.
This made Syrian refugees feel inadequate.
Azodae, a 31 year old former mechanic said
"The Germans see themselves here,
if you wanna be with us, you
have to catch up with us.
When you get here it's
like you're a newborn."
Another respondent was more explicit,
calling the system racist and explaining
there's no recognition that I'm coming
from Syria within 11th grade education
and that I wanna continue
to finish my education.
Why can't I just continue on? It's racist.
We left war and we came here
to be met by this racist system.
For some the lack of recognition
of their professional
history as human capital
that matters for the German
labor market regarded
on their giving up on an
attempt to secure equivalency.
So, in Bavaria, BMW hired people through
these temp agencies and a lot of people,
despite the fact that
you're not really earning
the credential, a lot of
people just went through
these temp agencies that
actually were exploitative
and took a little bit off
every euro they earned.
But for everybody, a main driver to enter
the German economy was a fear
that the German government
would not renew their
three year residencies
unless Syrians proved to be productive.
And the German government
actually ended up
transitioning to one year residencies,
which let people feeling
very, very worried.
They trusted Anglo Merkel but they worried
about what would come after her,
which we're, you know,
beginning to see now.
So, for women by contrast,
the credentialization requirement
cleared a pathway to the labor market.
Yarrah, who had married her husband,
a Palestinian refugee in Syria when
she was 15 years old,
said that she would not
have continued education
or worked in Syria.
"I dropped out of school
young," she told me.
"I wasn't a particularly good student
and I got married young.
In Syria, I would've taken care
of my house and our kids."
In Germany, however,
she wanted to become a dental hygienist.
Three years after her arrival,
she was finishing up her
B one and in the process
of applying for an
(Heba speaking German)
Similarly, Madwa who
arrived with her husband
and one child and who was
pregnant with a second,
knew that she would attend.
She would also enter the labor market.
She said, of course here
you need two incomes.
Shrugging when I asked
her if she'd discussed it
with her husband, she said,
"It's an obvious thing,"
like for her it was expected
that she would enter.
But here too, it's important
to highlight the role
of racism and shaping the
experiences of new arrivals.
The image on your screen
is of hateful messages
one woman received in her
mailbox from a neighbor.
Not only did new arrivals
see the policies as
the German state as exclusionary
or as one respondent
put it, a German system
that works for Germans.
But also they felt that they were expected
to relinquish parts of their
identities to better fit
German life culture or
leading culture in Germany.
In Germany where Turks are
substantial immigrant minority,
estimated to be about 5%
of the German population,
the Syrians are racialized
as Muslim in relation
to this group that is perceived
to not want assimilate.
Particularly meaningful for the
expression of human capital,
women were turned away from a job
because they wear the hijab.
For instance, a 22 year old woman was told
by a government employee at the job center
that she could not work in a daycare
while wearing her hijab
because it would send
the wrong message to the children, right?
So, this racialization, this gendered
and discrimination exists alongside
is integral to the system.
So, in sum, in Germany, the
system of credentialization
ignored labor market histories
and lengthened pathways
to the labor market.
There was a strong divergence by gender
and that people with long
labor market histories,
often men were disadvantaged
by the non recognition
and people without labor market histories
who were often women but also young people
were advantaged by investment
in credentialization.
However, there important
caveats given women's
unique experience of
racism in this system.
Three years into their asylum,
72% of Syrians remained
unemployed in Germany,
according to you know,
some data gathered in 2019,
despite a desperate need for
them in the German labor market
where unemployment at the
time was hovering at just 4%.
The erasure of skills
and abilities through
non recognition is detrimental to asylies
who have more to offer and
who experienced financial,
political and emotional
injury by not being able
to participate in the labor market.
It also injures the German state
that is looking for their contributions.
So, according to a lot of people,
the reason the Germans admitted, you know,
half a million Syrians is
because they wanted to use their labor.
The case emphasizes that in
addition to investment states
make through incorporation policies,
recognition is key to expressing
existing human capital.
In short, the presence of a
German system for Germans leaves
refugees feeling marginalized
economically and otherwise.
So, now that I presented my data,
I conclude by returning
to my main argument.
The global ethnography
centers the experiences of men
and women who come from similar
socioeconomic backgrounds in
their initial years and three
countries of permanent refuge.
It advances a theory of state
structured human capital
by showing that human
capital often conceptualizes
to determinate of refugee outcomes
is a product of national
incorporation policy.
And specifically whether
countries are willing
to invest in and recognize
refugee potential.
In Germany, a diminished
ability to use human capital is
an outcome of a lack of recognition
of immigrant histories as human capital.
In the United States,
a diminished ability to
use preexisting skills in
the labor market is an outcome
of a lack of investment
in newly arrived refugees
so that they can use
their skills and capacities productively
in the United States
economy and in Canada,
a mixture of imperfect re-investment
and recognition results
in an ability to use and
create new human capital.
These processes, as I've described before,
are gendered and racialized,
as are the welfare systems
that they derive from.
And so what are the
implications for this project?
I'm gonna leave you with three.
First, in accounts of refugee crises
and in international laws,
refugees are cast as
victims in receiving states
that offer these durable solutions
are often cast as saviors.
Implicit to this is the
racist idea that life
in the west is necessarily a privilege
and therefore countries are accomplishing
their humanitarian commitment
simply by admitting refugees.
But admission into American
poverty is no one's salvation.
Indeed, wealthy countries
that receive refugees,
including the United
States, Canada, and Germany,
are complicit in the colonial legacies,
foreign military interventions
and environmental degradation
that create the very
conditions from which refugees
are fleeing and within their borders,
they too are capable of violence,
the violence of minoritizing,
of denying living wages,
of a non recognition of people's humanity.
So, this project captures how
countries equip new arrivals
for their pursuit of a
good stable life through
the very same systems
that have long shaped
the contours of national belonging.
Second and following,
observing how the human capital
of those seeking refuges
structured reveals the ways
in which it matters well
beyond the labor market.
Language acquisition is
necessary for everything,
for making friends to securing citizenship
in all three of these countries.
And the ability to express human potential
is emotionally important.
How would any of us feel
if all we have accomplished
and built professionally suddenly became
completely meaningless
to everybody around us?
Finally, the study has
implications well beyond
the case of refugees or even immigrants
through a design that follows
the simultaneous experience
of people seeking refuge who are strangers
to these systems of social welfare.
We raise a mirror to
the systems themselves
and how they shape
inequality more broadly.
The national incorporation
policies that structure
the human capital refugees
are the same systems
which low income people
have traversed across
these three countries for
decades, right, if not centuries,
well before this cohort of
Syrian refugees arrived.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- [Leslie] I'm gonna move
over here so I can facilitate
the in person and the online questions.
I'm sure there's a lot.
It was a very rich talk, very provocative.
I think there's a lot that we could
get into from each of the three cases.
So, what I'll do is for
people online invite you
to either raise your hand or
put a question in the chat
and then folks in the room
if you raise your hand,
I'll do my best to make sure that everyone
can ask a question when they want to.
I'm not gonna unmute myself.
Okay, so any questions to
start with in the room?
- [Female Participant 1]
Thank you for the talk.
It was illuminating.
I think my first question is,
and I don't know if this
necessarily makes sense,
but the different
dimensions of integration,
and how could that comparison
when you brought in other factors,
because I think when
we think resettlement,
the typical or not typical, obviously,
the important markers are, you
know, does someone get work?
Does someone have access
to care and whatnot?
But there's also these
other dimensions and one
that's of interest to me is
like family reunification.
And so one thing that I've noticed
in a lot of this like conversation,
especially amongst Syrian
refugees in different countries
is that, oh well in the
United States it's able,
you're able to bring your family
after you have citizenship.
In Canada, it's a little
bit more difficult,
in Europe it's almost impossible.
So, did that also factor
into your analysis?
- Yeah, so my final chapter, so here
I'm really presenting on the
three country comparison,
there's two chapters in
my book that don't really,
that get short shifted in
this kind of presentation
'cause you can't really
do the whole thing in it.
And one is the final chapter,
which is called "Here and There,"
which is about both remittances
and family reunification.
What kinds of burdens and guilt
do people feel when they're here,
when they've made it and
their family is there,
in sort of destitution
and poverty, struggling.
And so, how do they bring them over?
And one of the arguments that I make is
that your ability to get employed,
to make an income but
also to learn language
is entirely related to your
ability to bring your family.
Because if you're put in a situation where
you're disadvantaged
and you're not attending
English classes and you're
not making enough money,
then the likelihood of
you being able to pay
for the citizenship,
which is expensive, right?
Unless you remain on
government services but also
be able to sit and take
the citizenship exam,
which is an English language exam,
they actually test you on
your English is very low.
So, actually in an intervention
that I did post book,
I started a citizenship
clinic at Boston University.
What I do is I bring people
who are learning Arabic,
students who are learning
in the Arabic department
with refugees who are trying
to study for the citizenship exam.
I developed a curriculum that teaches
to the civics exam and then they have
one-on-one tutoring with the
students and the teachers.
And we actually had 11 people
pass the citizenship exam
as a result of that, you know,
as a result of their hard work of course,
but as also as a result
of that intervention
because you know, it's
an exam that you can pass
if you study to it,
but there aren't really
that many resources to help
people cross that burden.
So, I think that these are
all related stories, right?
And we think about family reification
just on the basis of the laws,
but you need the resources to even be able
to qualify under those laws for sure.
In there are, you are absolutely right,
there are different restrictions
on family reunification.
So, there's the immediate
family which you can bring in
the United States prior to
securing your refugee status.
And in Canada, in some instances,
in Germany, they actually truncated that.
That's why it moved from
three year residencies
to one year residency.
So, that's a really
interesting case to look at
in terms of family reunification
because under subsidiary protection,
which is the one year protection,
you cannot reunify your family.
And that was their attempt to stop.
And that actually a lot
of people self deported
because they were fathers
who got to Germany
and their intention was
to unify their family.
They just didn't want
them to go on the boat
with them 'cause they were, you know,
worried about their family's safety.
And also 'cause it's very expensive.
So, they waited until they got to Germany
and they tried to reunify
with their families.
And then when they got the one
year subsidiary protection,
their families are In unsafe positions
in refugee camps and other places.
So, they just went back and
it's a really sad, sad scenario.
Yes, in the back? Thank you.
- [Female Participant 2]
So, thank you for this talk.
It was wonderful.
So, in the US and in Canada,
you mentioned phobia a little bit,
but then in Germany it seemed that racism
and the experience of
racism really came through.
Why do you think there
was that difference?
Or was that, was it a little
bit more nuanced even?
Like why did they experience it as racism?
- Yeah, I think, I think
that's a really good question.
I think that in the United States,
so I will tell you
another example, I mean,
I mean y'all just heard me
be micro aggressed here,
but in the German case,
in the German case,
it happens, in Europe, I'm sorry,
I told Leslie that I tend to veer,
so y'all have move me back
if I'm outside of that.
But, in every time I
give a talk in Germany,
and this is a roundabout
way to answer your question,
but every time I give a talk in Europe,
somebody asks me a bonkers
question about, you know,
that assumes that race doesn't
exist, every single time.
You know, maybe there's
like very few exceptions.
I was actually one argument he said,
"Well, you can't just make anything up.
Syrians and Italians are
the same skin tone, right?"
This was his argument, right?
And so when we think about it,
I think that in the United
States we address race
and racism in ways, we
have a different language.
Not to say that it's less
racist, I think, you know,
I don't think that we
can talk about magnitude.
I don't think it's a
useful conversation to have
about what places are more or less racist,
but I do think that we have a conversation
about it here whereas in the German case,
it's all talked about in terms of culture
and even educated academics.
Even sociologists will sit in front of me
and and be like, "Race
does not exist," right?
Oh, this is just cultural differences.
What we have as Germans
have a right to want
to have our culture in our country, right?
As though they didn't
do the Holocaust, right?
And so like, you know,
what does it mean to,
what does culture mean in that regard?
And I argue that this is a
story of race and racism.
This is an ordinal
categorization of people, right?
And so, you know, when we
think about these things,
we have to put them in that context.
And I think in Germany, in one's
case, we were very visible.
There were lots of people. It
was a highly politicized case.
Germany has a massive
history with Neo, you know,
they have massive neo-Nazi elements
and there's just not that much pushback.
And there's really American,
not American History, sorry,
there's a podcast called "Something X"
in the New York Times.
Does anybody, you know
what I'm talking about?
That was about Germany and about race
and racism in Germany and about, you know,
how people experience it
and the neo Nazi movement
and how it's infiltrated also
with the policing, et cetera there.
- [Leslie] So, we have
two questions online
and then we'll move to,
well we've got, we've got a lot.
So, we'll I'm gonna try to
put these together for us.
So, Ahmed thanked you for
an interesting presentation
and wanted to ask about
forms of resilience.
That participants expressed
that expanded their agency.
So, sort of the resiliency, I guess,
practices that demonstrated
the agency that they had.
- So, this is a story of agency
and fighting back, right?
It's a story of systems
that don't enable people
and it's a story of
agency and fighting back.
So, when I talk about structure,
when I'm talking about
the reason I'm focusing on
the welfare systems is to say that here
is the framework in which
people have to operate.
But people, the EITC, the
earned income tax credit
was a huge resource that people use,
the earn income tax credit,
for those who don't know is
a government subsidy
for low income families.
And it's actually one
of the more effective,
if you ask me what my two
favorite government subsidies are
or what two favorite, you know,
poverty interventions are.
Either earned income tax
credit and food stamps, right?
I mean, honestly, I mean
they're all, but like
it would be the first income
tax credit and food stamps.
And it's because I have
seen people use that money,
which comes in April as like
a little bit of a bulk money.
Its, you know, for low income families
with a lot of children
could be as much as $5,000
and use that to invest
in a car or to use that
to help them with the
down payment on a house
or to use that even to
invest in a business.
You know, people have also
sold property in Syria
at a huge, huge discount that they had.
You know, once things
calm down a little bit,
were able to use that money.
People, you know, people have, you know,
communicated with each other,
made partnerships with each other.
Sometimes those fail because
you're basically like,
you know, everybody's kind
of in a precarious place
and so it's really hard
to start a business.
But these are all different ways
that people have pushed back.
I also think that, you know,
learning language in these conditions is
a huge form of resilience
and a huge form of agency.
So, I see this as an entirely
a story of resistance.
And if you're interested in that also,
the afterward of the book is written
by people from each case.
So, it's written by a woman
from the United States,
a woman who resettled the United States,
a woman who resettled in Canada,
and a man resettled in Germany.
And they talk about it
from their own perspective,
sort of what they did
and how they managed.
And that was important
to me for two reasons,
was to do something, you know,
that was five years after their arrival.
But also to include
people's voices unfiltered
by my analysis in the book.
- [Ramon] So, I, hello.
Ramon, Political Science.
I have a point of praise
and a question to follow
on the point of praise
because I think there's,
to go back to the comment on colonialism,
the way that often even social
scientist frame immigration,
it reminds me of the way
that colonial governments
would talk about like the
Indian problem, right?
As if the problem is people as opposed
to what we are doing to people.
And so I love how your book says,
well is not this people but the systems
that they're turning into.
And then that not just with
a very rightful moral lens,
but also in an analytical lens.
And my question is about the German case
because in the US you make very clear,
I think convincingly so that
the welfare system is a racialized system.
You know, there's the work of civil fogs,
there's, you know, you can look at
the work of historian Elizabeth Hinton,
then in the case of Canada
you have a more, you know,
the multicultural approach,
in the case of Germany,
I kept, 'cause you did
mention there the huge
Turkish minority that exists in Germany.
- Yeah.
- How, I mean,
intuitively I would think
that there's something
about the way the systems
happen and design around,
not just around skilling
and certification,
but around this Turkish
minority that could
have effects on how they address Syrians.
Is this a thing or is it just me?
- Yeah, so the German minority
came through a guest labor project.
And so what's really interesting
about the German case
is until the 1990s they described
the German official stance
on immigration was Germany is
not a country of immigration.
It was like in there, like
that was their official policy
of immigration is Germany is
not a country of immigration.
It was only in 2000 that
they allowed anybody
with non-Germanic blood, kid you not,
non-Germanic blood to get Turkish citizen
to get, sorry German citizenship.
So, 100% this exclusionary story is
about German's like hegemonic sort
of white supremacist
notion of their country.
And there's really interesting stuff done,
I'm blanking on her name,
but there's an ethnographer
who linked the treatment of Turks
to the treatment of Jews in Germany.
And she has like a very interesting,
I can send you that cited in the book,
but I can't remember her name right now.
So, there's a really
interesting sort of story there.
- [Crowd Member] It was Elizabeth.
- Yes. Well, no no, not Elizabeth.
She was at Yale, not Liz.
No, it was somebody
older, somebody before.
Maybe it was Elizabeth.
Wait, Elizabeth, maybe, I'll
look it up. I'll look it up.
I don't wanna say the wrong
name, I'll look it up.
But, somebody who wrote a book about this.
And so, you know, when we think about it,
when we think about what a
racialized system is, right,
we have to think about, you know,
who does the system exclude?
And in the German case, you're right,
it's not exactly the
cases in the United States
where it's a system designed
to exclude, you know,
like this, you know, notion
of the welfare queen, right?
It's a very like racist system
through its like inception, right?
Language and the rhetoric around it.
In the German cases,
it's just a story of
refusing to include, right?
Of having this closed
system that only imagines
the German polity as white Germans,
even as their polity actually
becomes more and more diverse, right?
Even as Turkish people
become 5% of the population,
Syrians become 1% of the
population and the unwillingness
or inability to sort of shift the system.
Now there have been some attempts,
so there's a recognition act that was done
in 2012 and revamped in 2016,
but that's only for people
with formal credentials.
And what's really interesting
about that is the Germans
are really good about
publishing their data.
That is a point in their favor.
And the data shows that
they are very unlikely
to recognize Syrians even
when they are doctors
or lawyers with the formal credential.
So, there's only a 32% recognition rate
for Syrians who arrive in Germany versus
if you arrive from the European Union,
there's like an 87% recognition
rate for your credential.
- [Leslie] There's a
question about religion here,
so I'm gonna get back to it.
Just wondering maybe if you
can speak a little bit about,
so this is from Samita
about how religion factors
not only into sort of the daily lives
of resettled people or refugees,
but also maybe people who help volunteer
or participate in refugee resettlement.
And they also had a question like related
about the ways in which
refugees might be invited
into countries that seem secular
or there's a language of secularity,
but there's expectations
of certain acceptable
and unacceptable religions or practices.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
again, I talk about,
I'm kind of phobic to
talk about Islamophobia.
The reason why I don't
talk about Islamophobia
is because phobia is
something that you feel
that's like a visceral
reaction to something.
Instead, when we talk about
anti-Muslim sentiments,
I prefer to talk about it as a racism.
And the reason why I prefer to
talk about it as a racism is
because you can't understand
it unless you place it
within the American racial system, right?
Within the anti-black, anti, you know,
you know, the killing
of indigenous people,
the way that the system has
been anti-immigrant, right?
How our laws have transformed
around the fact that,
you know, that the imagined
beneficiary essence
as Sibil Fox's work became, you know,
low income Mexicans and
black people, right?
That's a very different kind of story
if you place it within that framework.
And who is, so, another way
to think about this is like,
you know, the reason why
Arabs in the United States
are identified as white on, you know,
all of the documents in
the census, et cetera,
is because you had to
be white by law in order
to be naturalized in the United States.
But George Dow, one of the primary cases
that that proved this, right?
Stood in front of a judge in, you know,
the early 19 hundreds
and said to the judge,
"I'm white because I am
related to Jesus," right?
'Cause this guy was Palestinian.
He's like, I'm white.
If you think Jesus was white,
I'm 100% white because we come from
the same place and he won.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So, whiteness in the United States has
always been based around
Christian framework.
And so when we think about this,
when we think about who's included
and who's excluded and how race works,
you have to think about
anti Muslim sentiment
as a form of racism.
Now, in terms of who helps,
yes, mosques are available.
Churches, you know, I'm
old enough to remember,
you know, in 2014, 2013, the
vast majority of the work
of resettlement was done
by evangelical churches
in the south of the United States, right?
So, like, you know, and it was this idea
of welcoming the stranger,
Jesus is a refugee, right?
So, there is, so religiosity
has always played
a role for people
helping across religions,
whether they wanna evangelize,
but also whether they just, you know,
feel like it's their
obligation to welcome people,
but also for co-ethnics
with other co-ethnics.
And then there was this move, you know,
that, you know, under Trump that we should
only be accepting Christian refugees.
So, of course religiosity
plays a role in who feels
the need to support whom
and whether and who actually
gets involved in the work
of resettlement for sure.
- [Leslie] One in the back there.
- Go ahead.
- [Female Participant
3] Thank you so much.
This is a great analysis.
And so these three examples
in terms of accepting.
Canada, like you said took refugees in,
is there a fundamental
reason why US and Germany,
the US and Germany systems
want the Canadian systems in the future?
Or its just evolutionary courses?
They will be gone from it?
- I think so. I think
they're fully capable.
Did I interrupt you? I'm so sorry.
Okay, I think they're,
I think so, I've been talking
about this a lot recently
because when the Ukrainian
displacement happened,
somehow people became interested
in displacement in general.
So, I got invited to give a lot of talks.
And one of the reasons that
one of the things that I say is
that, you know, when
Ukrainians were admitted,
for instance, over the US
Mexico border, the people,
the customs and Border
Patrol officers were told
by the Biden administration to use
their discretion when
it came to Ukrainians.
What that tells me is
that discretion was always
a possibility in that case,
at that border, right?
And so do they have the capacity
to converge with Canada?
Does Canada have the capacity
to do better? Absolutely.
I think the question is a
question of political will.
Do we actually have an
interest in this country
of reforming our systems,
not only for refugees,
but also for other immigrants
and also for low income people?
I think the answer
historically has been no,
I hope we see more of a convergence,
but I don't think, even though,
and I would argue I could make an argument
and economic argument,
I could say if you are
only interested in money and
you still wanna admit people,
it's more cost effective
for you to invest in them
in the beginning in terms of the return
that you'll get long term.
I don't make that argument
because I don't think
we should just assign
dollar values to people.
But I do think I could make that argument.
And so, you know, but the idea is
there's just not a willingness,
there is not an imagination
of the new arrivals
as beneficial to us.
Instead it's an imagination
of them as burdens, right?
Security threats, Muslims
who might do terrorism,
low income people who
are going to be drains
on the system, all of this rhetoric.
And so instead of investing our approaches
to mitigate threat, and that's
a completely different imagination, right?
Than a case where we actually
actively invest in people.
- [Male Participant] Yeah. Hi, I'm Hector.
So, my question, I haven't had my hand on-
- Oh, hi Hector.
- Hi.
I haven't gotten my
hands on your book yet,
so I apologize if it's, you
know, there and I'll get to it.
But my question is about
what here in the US
I've heard as like the
nonprofit industrial complex
and so trying to learn more
about how this idea of,
or how the assistance
part of your analysis,
how that looks in Canada and Germany.
If we think about the
nonprofits, which, you know,
from my understanding, you know,
are connected to the state,
are still state structured,
but are, you know.
- Yeah, they're
fundamentally state entities
in the United States because resettlement,
while technically a
government system is actually
entirely done in the
United States through NGOs.
In Canada, it's not, that's
not entirely the case
because your government assistance
does arrive directly from the government.
In the United States, your welcome money
arrives through the resettlement agencies.
I am, I am. How do I?
I feel like it's misplaced.
I, you know, the stuff,
the criticism of NGOs I
think is really well founded.
I made a decision in the book
to focus on government policies
because I think it's misplaced criticism.
Like, could NGOs do
better in their position?
Could they do better to advocate?
Could they recognize more
how unfair the system is?
Absolutely, right?
But the thing is, is that actually
after I published the book,
I have been surprised,
you know, Lutheran Refugee, you know,
the, one of the voluntary agencies,
which is a national,
runs a lot of different
resettlement agencies reached out to me
after the book and said,
"What can we do better?"
Right, so there is I think a willingness,
and I do wanna work with those people
for these intermediary effects
'cause this impacts people's
lives immediately, right?
And so I am really keen
on supporting, you know,
the work of NGOs who are tasked with this.
And so I'm reticent to participate
in that kind of rhetoric.
And the reason for that is because I think
that the real violence
and the real crisis lies
with the government just not funding this.
And so the NGOs are put
in an impossible position,
like, can we all do our work better?
Absolutely.
Is there really a way to do this well
given the resources that they have?
I don't think so.
- Got it. Thank you.
- [Female Participant 4] My
question is really related,
it's kind of, I guess similar to what
that the Lutheran organization asked you.
I'm wondering, I know
there's a lot of people
I think listening to this
that are involved in some way,
shape or form refugee
resettlement or integration,
which is a phrase I don't
like 'cause it means
integration into American
poverty, but in this room,
both in person and online.
So, I'm wondering what,
I'm sure this would be
an elongated response,
but if there's anything you could share
that you shared with the organization
that reached out to you and kind of what
would be the role of
those NGOs to advocate
for if the violence is with the state
to be part of, you know, upending that.
- Yeah, so there's, you know, so the,
what my response to them
was that I would be really
uncomfortable to come up
with those answers on my own.
So, what I suggested was a series where
we actually discussed
with key policy holders,
people who are interested
from across the country
to come in sort of communion
and have a conversation.
But the way I also approach it was to say
there's like three levels of this,
three levels that you can think
about in terms of how we can reform.
One is like the things that people can do
with the resources that
they have at the moment.
So, that's like using
volunteers for instance,
for things like tutoring,
for things like, you know,
you know, online language,
things that you don't need
sustainability for, for instance.
And not using them for things
that people crucially need, for instance.
Thinking about the rhetoric
that we use, right?
Is self sufficiency, when we
talk about self sufficiency,
do we talk about it as like the goal?
Do we say things like refugees need
to learn to be independent?
Or do we say, you know, this
is a really problematic policy,
we are gonna help you to
the extent that we are able
within the framework of
what we can do, right?
Which is a very different
approach to the same question.
Do we actually recognize,
I mean, you know,
unfortunately even of a
well-meaning organization has people
within their midst that are
just really problematic, right?
And so do we think about,
do we train our staff?
Do we have conversations
about what it means
to be, you know, respectful?
What it means to treat
people with dignity.
How you receive people, how
you speak to people, right?
Is that a part of how we sort
of identify and understand ourselves?
Do we talk about, do we
essentialize countries?
Do we say Iraqi are like this
and Palestinians are like that?
Just something that I heard said,
and Syrians are like this, right?
Do we use those kinds of language?
Is that allowed and accepted
within our organization?
Do we have opportunities for people
to learn English in the evenings?
Do we have opportunities for
people to learn English online?
Do we give rides to people?
I mean, there's just like a
million different examples,
both from an instrumental perspective,
but also from a rhetoric
and a language perspective.
The second, the meta level
of this is to think about,
okay, what do we wanna fundraise for?
What are we not doing now that we can,
that we want resources
to be able to do, right?
And the third level is how do we advocate?
What are our policy points
when we're advocating with the state?
What do we tell our lobbyists to say?
And so my goal is to work
with this organization
to be like, okay, if
you're actually interested,
let's work together and find
what these three things are,
what these three buckets of things are,
sort of dreams of changing the system,
dreams that are fundable and dreams
that don't need funding
and can be done right now.
- [Leslie] So that, so unfortunately,
that is all the time
that we have right now.
I invite those of you who are in the room
to stay after and just
have informal conversation
with Heba for a few minutes.
But on behalf of the
Program for Refugees Study
or for Refugees Versus
Displacement Humanitarian Response,
and the Center for Race,
Indigeneity and Transnational Migration,
I just wanna say thank you to all of you
and especially thank you to Heba for this.
(crowd applauding)